president trump upping the ante in his
feud with twitter
trump just signed an executive order
calling for regulations to punish social
media companies for political bias
he also took a big shot at twitter over
fact checking his tweets
take a look i think this if twitter were
not
honorable if you're going to have a guy
like this be your judge and jury
i think you shut it down as far as i'm
concerned but i'd have to go through a
legal process
how would you shut down i don't know i'd
have to ask the lawyers i'd have to go
through a legal process
if it were legal if it were able to be
legally shut down i would do it
i think i'd be hurting it very badly if
we didn't use it anymore
twitter is defending its decision but
facebook ceo mark zuckerberg ripped the
move
telling dana that social media platforms
should not be the arbiters
of truth okay
a lot to take in here dana when you
talked to zuckerberg
earlier what was the sense is this like
him kind of
needling a competitor
well i think there's they are rivals of
course but i think that you know
they get they get lumped together in
terms of big tech
and i think what the things that
zuckerberg was trying to say is that we
have a different approach and
if twitter wants to do that's okay but
he did say that he thought twitter made
a mistake
and that he doesn't think that the big
tech companies if you're going to be a
platform
just be a platform and and don't weigh
in
and i think that one of the things
that's lost in this discussion is
just how much the left really
disdains these social media companies
especially facebook because
facebook took that made that decision
that it wouldn't weigh in on political
speech
and you know speaker pelosi today ripped
mark zuckerberg
um they've been taking it on the chin
from even like joe biden
things that they should take down
president trump's uh
campaign ads or posts or speech uh his
uh
tweets that are cross-promoted on
facebook so this is like uh
in some ways what president trump is
doing you can maybe see
there's be some bipartisan support but
for very different
reasons like they both hate it i i think
that this is a slippery slope
for conservatives and i understand that
the communications decency act of 1996
of which i actually worked on the
committee
that that's 25 years old and maybe it
does need a little bit of updating but i
also think that if these companies don't
have that protection
censoring will be a much more likely
thing because
they're be liable for all sorts of
things that put on their platforms
probably better just to let it all
go um
i'm not so sure about that i think you
could maybe target the regulation a
little bit better gutfeld what do you
think do you think this is going to blow
back
and and hurt the president or do you
think that twitter might have stepped in
it
and uh might might uh regret what
they've done
who i don't know i mean
trump loves to kick the tires of
everything
this feels like he's kicking the tires
see what he can do and gets people riled
up
he um it's hard because
like it look the
the entirety of communication in culture
is
overwhelmingly leftward entertainment
media academia
that's all left it's too late to roll
back that stuff
so there's the fourth horseman it's the
one that you should be concerned about
because if this horseman social media
joins the other ones
then it's really over because this
horseman controls the algorithms
and that controls the news it controls
everything
so i understand that when they when
twitter decides to fact check
we instinctively think who's doing the
fact checking
who is it is it this idiot that called
everybody in the white house nazis
because that's what happens everywhere
else they're overwhelmingly progressive
in leftward they think that
trump's racists they think his followers
are deplorable so do you really want to
hand
do you really want them in control so
that's what i think
everybody's concerned about because we
like i said before
if if fact checking is a highway the red
cars get pulled over
and the blue cars don't and i think
that's where a lot of this animus
comes from there's it's not gonna be
it's not gonna be fair and balanced
like this beloved network
marie uh why can't joe biden just get on
twitter if he knows how to do it
and just you know reply back to the
president if he says something he thinks
is crazy
why is he why does he need big tech guys
to help him run his campaign
well this isn't about joe biden and i
think everyone probably knows by now
that
i'm not on twitter because of the
bullying and the threats
and i i know jesse i know you're trying
to make it about him but
this is i deleted those three i
apologize
this is donald trump trolling twitter he
can't shut it down he knows he can't
shut it down
and the real question for twitter is
whether they are comfortable with their
platform
being used by anyone including the
president to promote
hateful violent dangerous or
outright fabrications to millions of
people and that's a really hard question
so you know the fact that donald trump
is is taking this action today is really
not a legal one it's a political one
this is his favorite kind of political
action it's grievance politics
but from experience let me tell you
there's a lot of conservatives on
twitter
a lot of them went after me for a long
time that's why i'm not on there
so this idea that twitter is not safe
for conservatives is just not
true it's not borne out by the facts
all right so lawrence i mean marie makes
the point that
you know twitter doesn't want to have
people going onto their platform and
lying and making threats
doing all this stuff okay so they'd have
to police it
the left and the right but that's not
what's gonna happen what's gonna happen
is
they're just gonna over police the right
and then just
look the other way when anybody on the
left does anything crazy or lies
yeah and i think the big problem here is
the problem with most companies when
they get away from their value system
the fact of the matter what the action
that they're taking right now
is violating their mission statement
they said their mission statement is to
share information and content without
barriers
this is a new barrier and so they're
violating that they're trying to be
the one between the content creator
and the people that they're trying to
reach and look i don't think the
president is trying to shut down twitter
i don't think that
that has nothing to do with that what
he's trying to do is bring awareness
to a big issue now me as a conservative
i believe that
this is a private company they can they
can do whatever they want to do
but i think is it a bad business
practice
to violate your mission statement as
well as the main person like
donald trump is everybody's coming there
to see what he's he says on twitter
he sets the news cycle on twitter every
single day
those people will leave when he leaves
um and so i think when it comes to
competition
i think they let their politics get the
best of them
yep and we know what their politics are